i was an ios developer so i'm a bit of a
apple nerd when it comes to this kind of
stuff when you get like a new thing
[Music]
happy
wednesday
look what came in the mail
yeah
i ordered the new macbook pro
this is my 2018
15-inch macbook pro
and i ordered a new one
a 14-inch macbook pro
with 64 gigabytes unified memory two
terabytes of ssd 10 core cpu 32 core gpu
with the uh the new chip m1 max i think
so excited literally ordered this in
december and it came today it's march
2nd
so
let's open benny benny
benny this is not
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
here she is
my new computer
i haven't bought a mac in a while so
let's see what it comes with what
oh oh oh it's like the old charger
and a usbc
so oh right because it does it come with
the oh it still comes with this thing
iphones don't come with these anymore
but
i guess um
macbooks do it's kind of annoying that
they went back to this because now i
have usb cs everywhere
and now this is probably the only cord
that'll work for this one because i
threw out it's very boxy it you know
what it reminds me of like the old
school macbook pros thing or the
macbooks the white ones
it's very square
dang what in the
wow it's so square i actually had not
realized
that the edges were so square like this
it feels very retro and i am
very into it okay let's open
oh
hello
first launch look at this
never typed on this kind of keyboard oh
hello hello hello gorgeous dude look at
how small this bezel is i know that a
lot of y'all probably have macbooks but
yeah the new macbook hype is real i like
the feel of keyboard this is a work of
art
i mean i was an ios developer so i'm a
bit of a apple nerd when it comes to
this kind of stuff when you get like a
new thing
[Music]
hello everybody happy thursday wanted to
do a little bit of show and tell
because it's been a while first off this
is our bedroom and look at all these
plants that we have also we put the tv
here we are about to embark on a huge
kitchen renovation in our house we are
trying to clear out the whole first
floor because we're gonna redo flooring
we do painting completely gut the
kitchen install a brand new kitchen and
so we're trying to move all the stuff
downstairs up to here and so our bedroom
is looking real lush and it's like a
bedroom slash living room and it's kind
of like really nice to hang out here to
the point where i'm kind of like dude we
really didn't have very much in our
bedroom before this i was talking to
scott about this our look i think is
like scandinavian bright clean
and light woods paired with mid-century
modern mid-century like vintage
furniture as well as plants and then a
little bit of like japan d mixed in
there cool to figure out what we
actually like now but yes uh other
things i wanted to show and tell
it's time for this month's sakurako box
who is a sponsor of today's video so
thank you to sakudaku for sponsoring for
those of you who don't know sakurako is
a monthly subscription box that sends
japanese sweets snacks treats and tea
pairings right to your door every month
there is a different theme so you're
gonna get different snacks all these
snacks are from japan and they're like
authentic really traditional ones that
you can't find at like asian grocery
stores and markets so wanted to open the
april box with y'all the april box the
third
as usual comes with a really cute
postcard and then
the snack guide which is really helpful
it has uh like dietary allergy
restrictions what's like what are the
different snacks where they're from very
helpful very fun to read honestly i
learn a lot about my own culture but the
april box is sakura matsuri sakura
festival because it is sakura sees it
which i miss it because usually this is
when i go to japan and i get to see
some sakura and i'm not doing that this
year because kovid but this is good
enough all right so in this box we
immediately open it to this huge bag of
sakura daisuke look how pretty these are
these are like cookies with like
gorgeous
pretty
sakura things it comes packed y'all
oh my
look at all these snacks it's really
packed it comes ooh nice ningle jumbo
usually also comes with a piece of bread
and then every box also includes a
japanese wear this is the wear for the
april box so if you want the april box
then make sure to order before april in
order to get to this box
[Music]
the texture is so good so if you'd like
to sign up for sakurako then make sure
to go to the link in the description box
down below or use code mayuko at
checkout to get five dollars off your
very first sakurako order thank you
again in sakuraku for sponsoring
now let me tell you about the other
things in the show and tell that i've
got going on right now actually going on
with the spring vibe you know i think
the funny thing about living in san
diego is that it's like constantly
spring so when it's spring it's a very
subtle change of season versus in other
parts of the world it's a lot more
drastic but feeling real spring vibes
right now so i wanted to show you
my nails look at how cute they are i've
been doing my nails pretty frequently
like every week it's my kind of like
sit down do things for me thing also
it's very satisfying to like take care
of your hands and your fingers that's
the other show and tell oh did i show
you my new phone case
this is really cute this is very my yuko
uh i got this online after i was like i
literally googled snoopy phone cases and
a lot of them are
not super cute but i thought this was
really cute and it's snoopy with their
surfboard and i was like chill
that's me oh and then the last thing i
drew ellie
look
i drew her i made this the other day
because i was like i've had ellie for
almost two years and i haven't drawn her
yet this is just like the style that i
do for my pets those are my updates
that's show and tell
i guess which i guess vlogs
are basically show and tell reels so
i've got a meeting in 30 minutes which
means i need to finish some work so
let's get to it guess where we are again
i feel like i always vlog when we're
here we're at the costco gas station
because gas is more expensive since the
last time i vlogged i just finished uh
teaching for honco academy and it was a
it's a hard class i taught like view
life cycles and subclassing views and
stuff like that which is tough stuff and
our students ask really good questions
uh which is awesome it's interesting
because i feel like this whole
experience and opportunity helps me to
brush up on my technical knowledge
literally it feels like it refreshes the
cash on my brain tomorrow night i have a
very interesting opportunity to speak
on a japanese tv show
live stream
show sort of thing
and uh
i'm very i'm kind of nervous for it i
actually didn't need to do a good amount
of prep for it i'm hoping that my
japanese is gonna be good enough but i i
did have a meeting in japanese today and
i have another one
tomorrow before my thing
and so hopefully that my brain will re
my brain cash will be refreshed
for japanese too you know
[Music]
we'll give costco permission to make
such big
pizzas
yes
it's friday
happy friday everybody it's finally
freaking friday
just finished up lunch and uh it's
15 to 1 right now
and uh
i am gonna prep for
the event that i'm speaking at later
um i have a lot of stuff to do today and
not enough time to do it which is
usually my fridays are either that or
they're like
wow i have so much time today let's do
all the things that i've been neglecting
for the rest of the week but today is no
not such one day
but um
i was thinking of signing up for an ieee
membership
i've never signed up for ieee before
because i thought it was like for
intellectual engineering people only but
they do a lot of cool stuff
like research and stuff and i was just
like
i think i want to sign up for it i feel
like such a computer science person
right now it's a hundred and four
dollars
per year are you an ieee member
let me know i just never thought to join
it or anything but
yep gonna prepare i'm gonna turn on my
japanese brain
let's do this
hello still friday
uh it's 6 33 and i'm done
with work i didn't finish everything but
i did the things that were most
important
and i've decided to go eat dinner
with some high school friends really
crashed their dinner because i wasn't
originally gonna be able to make it and
then now i'm making it so
i'm gonna go because i can't i'm really
excited and i'm even
wearing jeans which i literally haven't
worn these jeans in so long so i'm sorry
ellie i'm sorry i can't bring you to
dinner
don't look at me like that
why do you have to look so sad
i'm sorry i wish i could bring you
everywhere i know
[Music]
good morning it's saturday and
i'm on my way to go surf usually we have
a group of four and two of those is me
and scott and scott has an ear infection
right now so it's just me and meeting up
with my other friend in la jolla to go
surf today let's catch some waves y'all
let's do it
so stoked but also it's gonna be cold
but it's gonna be fun all right we're
here just take a look at the waves they
look nice today much better than last
weekend i'm just gonna wait for my
friend just based on everybody wearing
booties today it seems like the water is
gonna be really cold so
it's gonna feel great fortunately i
cannot vlog myself surfing
and so unfortunately all you'll see is
the before and after
[Music]
we finished surfing
how was it
it was great
any day in the water oh the show
us two are like the most consistent of
our surf crew i know to go you see our
lats are getting very big
we're hungry now so we're gonna go eat
eastown
[Music]